upon which they place drops and then
heal the smoke through tubes inserted in
their nostrils
this was the first acquaintance of white
men with tobacco
the fragrant leaves of the indians
quickly spread around the world
today the labor and skill of thousands
of families
goes into the growing and processing of
tobacco
tobacco plants grow on millions of acres
of fertile soil soil that might
otherwise be used to produce food
from cure tobacco leaves such generally
known products the snuff chewing tobacco
pipe tobacco cigars and cigarettes are
made
more stores sell tobacco than bread and
money spent on tobacco could pay for
half our schools
this then is an example of a product
that represents one of america's largest
farm crops and one of the most
controversial consumer articles
what does this product contain
and how does it affect those who use it
what tobacco smoke contains is simple to
determine
here is a scientifically designed
apparatus for collecting the content of
the smoke under controlled conditions
smoking is a process of dry distillation
by dry distillation we mean the
transformation of dry substances into
vapor
as the tobacco is smoked all the
products normally inhaled by a smoker
are collected in these bottle traps
filled with liquids
supplementary traps called bubblers
catch any substances not collected in
the flasks
the liquid in two of the flasks absorbs
the nicotine
and in the other two flasks it collects
the tarry substances out of the burning
tobacco
from the first group of flasks chemists
isolate nicotine by distillation
the amount of nicotine obtained in this
process is of course small and can only
be measured by very delicate instruments
the ultraviolet spectrophotometer for
instance is often used to measure minute
amounts of nicotine
different cigarettes even of the same
brand sometimes vary in weight and
quantity of nicotine
variations from one to three milligrams
per cigarette have been recorded
one milligram is about this much and
three times this amount could cause
nicotine poisoning
the liquid in the second pair of flasks
contains tars
it is first diluted with water then
chloroform is added
the chloroform dissolves the tars from
the solution
since chloroform and water do not mix
the chloroform mixture separates from
the water as soon as the shaking stops
finally chloroform is evaporated out of
the mixture by boiling leaving the tars
behind in the measuring cup
cigarette tars consist of a variety of
substances which can be further
separated chemically
here are some of the more important
constituents of cigarette tarts
some may be considered irritants other
stimulants and some as having no known
effect upon the human organism
all smoke including cigarette smoke
contain some carbon monoxide a poisonous
gas that combines readily with the
hemoglobin of the red blood cells and
prevents it from absorbing oxygen in the
lungs and giving it off to the tissues
very little is known about how much harm
carbon monoxide from smoking does
all these tarry substances are the
products of burning
they are not in the green tobacco leaves
but unlike tars nicotine is found in the
unburned tobacco
in smoking some of the nicotine enters
the body
when we light a cigarette about 25 of
the nicotine is destroyed chemically by
fire
behind the glowing tip in the zone where
tobacco is heated to a medium
temperature
gases containing nicotine arise from the
leaves
about 30 percent of these gases pass out
into the atmosphere while the remaining
45 percent continue to flow with the
main air current towards the mouth
however the major portion of the
nicotine does not reach the mouth
it is deposited on the cold tobacco
particles which it passes on the way
in consequence only some 15 percent of
the total quantity of nicotine enters
the mouth
nicotine enters the body primarily
through the air passages and lungs
however some nicotine is dissolved in
the saliva of the mouth and swallowed
thus reaching the stomach directly
from the stomach the portal vein carries
it to the liver where some chemical
changes occur which are not yet fully
understood
but most of the nicotine enters the
lungs with the inhaled air
from the lungs it is carried to the left
side of the heart and from there it is
rapidly distributed to all tissues of
the body
this is why the smoker feels the effects
of smoking almost as soon as he lights
the tobacco
carried by the blood
nicotine reaches the nerve cells where
it induces a complex set of reactions
the drug acts mainly on three parts of
the nervous system
on the ganglia or switchboards of the
autonomic nervous system
on the junction between nerves and the
muscle
and on the brain itself
at these points nicotine first
stimulates the nerve cells
then gradually slows down functions and
even paralyzes them
as a consequence many types of reactions
may go on at different rates and at
different places in the body
simultaneously producing involved and
often unpredictable effects effects
which vary with each individual
animal experiments enable us to observe
the action of massive doses of nicotine
note the blood vessels in this rabbit's
ear
an injection of nicotine affects the
rabbit's blood vessels dramatically
watch how the small arteries in the
rabbit's ear gradually disappear
as the blood vessels tighten up under
the stimulating action of nicotine
in this experimental setup effects of
nicotine from smoking can be measured
with special instruments
although the smoker absorbs relatively
small amounts of nicotine sensitive
instruments can record its effect
for instance these thermocouples record
the influence of nicotine upon the body
temperature
in this experiment we see that the skin
temperature gradually drops from point
80 on the graph to about 65 or 15 points
the skin temperature drops because blood
vessels constrict under the influence of
nicotine and less blood reaches the skin
experiments with animals help dramatize
the effect of nicotine on the nerve
cells of the heart
by applying the drug directly to the
exposed nerve of a rabbit's heart we
induce a change in rhythm
to understand better what is happening
let us look at a schematic drawing
in the experiment nicotine was applied
at the spot indicated by the arrow
and this is one nerve cell called a
ganglion cell
nicotine first stimulates the nerve
cells
then it paralyzes them
see how the rabbit's heart first beats
slower then speeds up as the nicotine
stimulates and subsequently paralyzes
the nerve cells of the heart
in the observation chamber the research
scientist can measure simultaneously the
action of nicotine upon the human heart
breathing skin temperature and blood
pressure
the multiple graph indicates that this
man's heart has not been visibly
affected by the nicotine
the graft in the middle reproduces the
pattern of breathing
we've seen that nicotine causes the
heart to beat more rapidly and often
irregularly
we've also seen that nicotine causes
blood vessels to contract
there is a connection between the two
when the heart beats faster it pumps
more blood through the blood vessels
which nicotine has made narrower as a
result blood pressure increases
smoking is dangerous for persons
suffering from disorders of blood
vessels of the extremities such as in
the case of burgers disease
to demonstrate the action of the
autonomic ganglion cells of the
intestines we place a piece of rabbit
intestine in a glass container
the rhythmic movement of the intestine
continues even after it is separated
from the animal
the scribe shows normal peristalsis
now we inject nicotine into the solution
the reaction is violent
this is one reason why doctors often
advise patients with peptic ulcers
chronic heartburn or [ __ ] intestines
to abstain from smoking
nicotine also acts upon the central
nervous system
it stimulates it and produces a
quickening of brain activity which
creates a feeling of nervousness and
excitement
this rabbit reacts calmly to petting and
tapping
but as soon as nicotine has acted upon
it the rabbit reacts to the same
treatment with convulsions and tremor
nicotine that enters the lungs of the
smoker spreads rapidly through the body
in turn it is excreted in urine
saliva and sweat
after several days all nicotine leaves
the body but the urge to smoke remains
this urge is the result of a complex set
of causes most of them psychological
contrary to other habit-forming drugs no
bad after effects are known to result
from giving up smoking
the question is then
why do people smoke
it's sociable
i never thought i smoked
i started smoking when i was quite young
my parents smoked so do i
most people start smoking in imitation
of a hero or because they think that it
makes them look important grown up or
sophisticated
or they just stumble into the habit
but once formed it is a hard habit to
break
on the other hand smoking is not an
inborn inherited or natural urge
beginners almost without exception find
smoking irritating
sometimes reactions are quite violent
and yet smoking is a widespread social
habit
so widespread that considerable money is
spent on the study of its effects
what are the conclusions of research at
this time
for one thing there seems to be
agreement that smoke causes irritation
of air passages
or smoker's cough is a well-known sound
of the many tar compounds in the tobacco
smoke we cannot tell with certainty
which one or ones cause irritation
our way of life makes it necessary for
many people to live in air polluted with
industrial smoke dust and car exhaust
add to this the irritation of tobacco
smoke and draw your own conclusions
experiments with mice are being
conducted in several universities
scientists suspect that certain
constituents in the smoke probably some
of the tarry substances may cause cancer
in the respiratory tract especially in
the lungs of smokers
by smearing tires obtained from tobacco
smoke and polluted city air on the skin
of mice scientists have already
succeeded in inducing cancer in mice
research in this area is relatively new
observers also point at the high
incidence of lip and tongue cancers
found among pipe smokers
the increase in heart ailments in recent
years alerted medical research to a
closer observation of smoking habits of
heart patients
there seems to be considerable agreement
about the effect of smoking upon the
human organism but a great deal more
work is needed to explain the
potentially dangerous effects of smoke
tars
smoking is a widespread social habit
a habit very easily acquired but very
hard to break
helped by advertising and glamorizing it
makes new converts easily especially
among the young
armed with these facts
it must be the decision of each and
every individual
whether he or she
will take the risks of smoking